près de 10000 personnes défilent dans
les rues de Nantes pour une Bretagne
réunifiée ils veulent profiter de la
réforme territoriale pour rattacher leur
département à la Loire-Atlantique à la
Bretagne la loi Atlantique n’aurait
jamais dû être séparé des quatre autres
départements une option pour le moment
écartée par le gouvernement il faut bien
que le peuple se bouge sinon les
politiciens ils font ce qu'ils veulent
et ils demandent surtout pas au peuple
il demande rien du tout dans cette foule
des militants de tout bord des
écologistes à l'UMP du PS à l'UDI en
passant par le Parti Breton ou encore le
collectif des bonnets rouges à l'origine
de ces manifestations la réforme
territoriale de François Hollande qui
veut créer de grandes régions à
l'échelle européenne
ce sera Toulon jeu de la réforme de
notre organisation territoriale de
grande région les Français ne peuvent
pas attendre le président frappe un
grand coup avec la réforme territoriale
qui remanie la carte de France en
faisant passer le nombre de régions de
22 à 14 une réforme qui va vite tourner
au casse-tête
identitaire
administratif
et parlementaire
pour ne découpe pas les régions en
fonction du poids de tel ou telle grand
ténor socialiste peut-être que le
calendrier monsieur le ministre n'est
pas absolument génial quand la moitié
des sénateurs de l'assemblée sont
renouvelables ce qui est
qu'on va refaire la France en trois
journées de débat nous allons vous
raconter le bras de fer entre le
gouvernement et les sénateurs sur la
réforme territoriale un projet de loi
qui touche particulièrement la Haute
Assemblée représentante des
collectivités locales aujourd'hui on n'a
aucune garantie c'est rien de le dire
sur le fait que ce texte passe mais la
volonté du gouvernement c'est que le
débat est mieux c'est que la réforme se
fasse mais pas dans les approximations
dans les raccourcis dans les amalgames
après l'échec cuisant des municipales et
des européennes François Hollande a
besoin d'une réforme emblématique pour
relancer son quinquennat il joue alors
son bateau avec la réforme territoriale
objectif s'attaquer aux millefeuille
administratives une réforme a priori
bien perçue par les Français le 3 juin
2014 il publie une tribune dans
l'ensemble de la presse régionale ainsi
qu'une nouvelle carte de France de 14
grandes régions avec une condition on ne
détache pas un département de sa région
d'origine
Hervé Le Bras et démographe auditionné
par le Sénat il regrette que l'Elysée
n'est consulté aucun expert
ça s'est tramé dans un très grand secret
ou du moins ça s'est tramé au sein d'un
univers politique très étroit donc je
peux pas dire moi je m'ennuie que des
échos vraiment parcellaires mais je peux
vous donner un exemple d'écho à midi le
lundi qui précédait la décision
puisqu'elle a été annoncée le mardi
matin le lundi à midi la région des Pays
de la Loire étaient regroupée avec la
région Centre dans zen grandes Loire si
vous voulez d'Orléans à Saint-Nazaire et
à 7h du soir la région des Pays de la
Loire était mise avec le Poitou et on
m'a assuré que c'était sûr c'était acté
et on me demandait mon avis qui a
d'ailleurs été négatif et puis un Hunter
j'ai eu une un coup de téléphone des
gens de des Pays de la Loire avec qui je
suis en relation depuis longtemps ils
m'ont dit NON NON maintenant on vient
d'apprendre qu'on restait seul qu'on
restait la région des Pays de la Loire
c'est donc une indication que ça s'est
fait vraiment dans une précipitation
un découpage fait dans la précipitation
mais l'idée elle n'est pas nouvelle
depuis 20 ans les rapports s'accumulent
et proposent de réformer la carte et les
deux arguments phares du président ne
date pas non plus d'hier le premier
avoir des régions fortes de taille
européenne le second faire des économies
en simplifiant le millefeuille
territorial
on peut arriver à une dizaine de
milliards d'euros d'économies parce que
10 milliards d'euros c'est à peu près 5%
de la masse globale
des collectivités locales la masse
globale des budgets des collectivités
locales c'est 250 milliards mais une
étude de 2008 vient tempérer ses propos
commandés par le Conseil régional de
Haute-Normandie lui-même elle porte sur
l'impact économique de la fusion entre
la haute et la Basse-Normandie c'est la
seule étude exhaustive sur ce sujet ces
conclusions le mariage coûterait jusqu'à
15 millions d'euros dans les 10
premières années la fusion ne
rapporterait de l'argent qu'au bout de
25 ans vous avez des économies d'échelle
liées à une mutualisation en fait de
d'un certain nombre de travaux de
fonctions mais ces économies d'échelle
elles sont quand même limitées et c'est
à dire que si on prend l'exemple des
lycées vous avez des lycées dans
Basse-Normandie des lycées en
Haute-Normandie vous allez pas les
regrouper pour faire des économies
d'échelle il y a il y a peut-être un
petit peu d'optimisme sur la
mutualisation et les économies d'échelle
qui peuvent résulter des fusion
si la fusion entre la basse et la
Haute-Normandie semble aller de soi
d'autres régions ont peur d'y perdre
leur identité face à ces craintes le
Premier ministre Manuel Valls s'engage
personnellement et n'hésite pas à aller
rassurer les élus locaux comme ici à
Annonay en Ardèche
ce sera donc pour beaucoup de Français
un changement mais un changement qui ne
menace en rien nos identités régionales
elles existent nos identités locales les
identités locales ont traversé
l'histoire au-delà des découpages
administratifs et elle continueront de
le faire grâce notamment à vous tous
élus qui savait faire vivre les
spécificités de nos territoires
une France d'abord découpée en
département après la Révolution il a
fallu attendre 1954 pour qu'il soit
regroupés en région et si vous avez de
Nantes vous avez le père des régions
c'est cet homme Serge Antoine à l'époque
jeune et Narc à la Cour des comptes en
1954 il est chargé de dessiner ses
nouvelles entités administratives et
s'appuient sur les découpages de
plusieurs administrations comme l'armée
ou les Eaux et Forêts un travail qui lui
prendra près d'un an je me suis rendu
compte que c'était très difficile de
travailler parce que chaque
administration n'avait pas de la même
le même découpage de la France certains
avaient découpé la France en 8 grandes
régions d'autres en 25 comme les
conservations des autres et Forêts avec
sa femme Aline il va travailler sur des
calques qu'il mettra directement sur les
fenêtres et si certains mariages vont de
soi d'autres relèvent de critères plus
artificiels comme le trafic téléphonique
si la Lozère téléphone plus à
Montpellier et moins Marseille je l'ai
rattaché à Montpellier 21 régions
sortent des cartons mais pour leur père
lui-même il fallait aller plus loin
à l'époque
dans 59 pour dire attention on fait ça
c'est bien c'est commode c'est rapide
c'est pas coûteux et on met il faut
aller plus loin et il faudrait regrouper
les régions où il faudrait qu'elle se
regroupe
à l'époque ces
régions vivent pour qu'elles aient du
pouvoir il faudra attendre les lois de
faire de 1982 et des élections au
suffrage universel direct
depuis la réforme du territoire est un
serpent de mer beaucoup de dirigeants
politiques s'y sont frottés et ont
échoué comme le général de Gaulle avec
son fameux référendum de 1969
plus récemment en 2008 Nicolas Sarkozy
lance la création du conseiller
territorial une des réformes phares de
son quinquennat il s'agit d'une
simplification d'une amélioration
considérable
mais ce n'est pas une solution simpliste
c'est une solution qui fait fi des
querelles sans fin et sans issue entre
les pro département et les pro région ce
n'est ni la mort des régions ni celle
des départements c'est l'émergence d'un
pôle Région Département doté d'un élu
comme un
vraiment plus je travaille puis je me
demande pourquoi il n'y a pas pensé
avant
une réforme qui ne verra pas le jour
elle sera supprimée par François
Hollande à son arrivée au pouvoir
le 18 juin dernier Bernard Cazeneuve
ministre de l'Intérieur présente sa loi
en conseil des ministres c'est le
premier volet de la réforme territoriale
que contient-il principalement la carte
des régions de François Hollande et un
nouveau calendrier pour les élections
départementales et régionales le jour
même Bernard Cazeneuve est auditionné au
Sénat chambre par excellence des
collectivités et donc saisi en premier
sur ce texte pour la première fois le
ministre se retrouve face au sénateur
j'ai plaisir à être avec vous quelques
heures après que le texte a été présenté
en Conseil des ministres parce que je
sais l'importance que revêt pour votre
assemblée le ton est courtois mais le
message lui et ferme ce que nous
souhaitons c'est ne pas attendre
davantage c'est prendre le risque
d'essayer c'est de faire des
propositions qui ne sont pas un solde de
tout compte parce que dans cette
assemblée les propositions ne sont
jamais seules de tout compte monsieur
grosdier monsieur le ministre le ton
monte rapidement car les sénateurs eux
ont une autre préoccupation les
élections sénatoriales du 28 septembre
et le texte arrive au pire moment au
Sénat pour la première fois dans
l'histoire de République est peut-être
de l'État français parce que même sous
l'Ancien Régime ça se serait jamais
produit comme ça on a quand même eu des
régions des immenses régions dont une
qui va réunir le plateau de Langres à la
Baie de Somme et l'autre La Rochelle à
Bourges qui ont été définies en une
après-midi par les caprices de cours et
non pas par une réflexion approfondie
alors je crois monsieur le ministre que
l'espère que le Sénat pourrait
s'exprimer dans toute sa sagesse pour
retra cette cartographie et si vous
voulez vraiment vous tenez absolument à
des grandes régions et que vous voulez
des régions pertinentes je vois pas en
quoi le fait de d'éventuellement séparer
un département de sa région d'origine
serait un tabou absolu qui serait
absolument viable moi je ne suis pas du
tout ce qui considèrent qu'il y a les
bons modernistes et les mauvais
conservateurs et que les mauvais
conservateurs seraient plus
particulièrement représentés dans cette
assemblée je remercie monsieur le
ministre Bernard Cazeneuve de son sens
de la pédagogie
mais le temps presse le gouvernement
veut une adoption définitive du texte
avant la fin de l'année il demande donc
une procédure accélérée il y aura bien
deux lectures dans les deux chambres
mais sans le délai de six semaines entre
la présentation en conseil des ministres
le 18 juin et l'arrivée du texte au
Sénat le 3 juillet derrière les échanges
policés la fronde s'organise
d'un côté socialiste vert et centriste
le clan des défenseurs du texte
de l'autre une alliance de circonstances
entre communistes du MP et radicaux de
gauche opposé au projet de loi
premier grief le calendrier ne souhaite
pas
à débat à la hussarde il faut
effectivement prendre le temps de se
débat que y compris un débat public avec
la population sera à mon avis absolument
nécessaire et donc par exemple nous
sommes effectivement contre les
procédures d'urgence que le gouvernement
voulait en-tête et d'imposer pour
permettre de faire adopter compris donc
en juillet très rapidement un texte
comme celui-là autre grief le texte
porte sur la carte et le calendrier des
élections locales mais pas sur les
compétences des régions
les sénateurs accusent le gouvernement
de mettre la charrue avant les bœufs
si le gouvernement comprend qu'il vaut
mieux attendre l'automne et le débat sur
les compétences pour faire en même temps
les compétences et la carte et bien on
travaillera ensemble au mois d'octobre
mais on refait pas la carte d'abord et
les compétences après
des critiques sur la procédure mais
aussi sur le fond les sénateurs de
départements ruraux s'inquiètent plus
particulièrement de l'enclavement de
leur territoire dans ses nouvelles
régions quand on fait de très grandes
régions et qu'on supprime les
collectivités de proximité ça pose un
problème considérable quand par exemple
le département que je représente est
rattaché à Lyon ronalpes à 11 heures de
train aller-retour ou à 9h de route
aller-retour ça pose quand même un vrai
problème il y a un autre problème qui
est fondamental fondamental c'est la
représentation des départements
affaibliographie il y a 15 ou 20
départements où il y a une démographie
faible dans les nouvelles régions
ils sont complètement sous représentés
voire pas représenté du tout d'ailleurs
dans le texte de loi du gouvernement il
y a une garantie d'un élu régional
minimum par département que peut faire
un élu d'un département dans un conseil
régional de 150 élus
le soir même les opposants au texte
gagnent une première bataille
ils obtiennent la création d'une
commission spéciale pour examiner la loi
qui va recommencer à zéro le travail sur
ce texte chaque sénateur peut désormais
postuler pour en faire partie c'est la
première réunion de la commission
le rapporteur le bureau mettre en place
le calendrier d'audition ce qu'on a que
quelques jours la commission spéciale
représente tous les groupes politiques
au Sénat en fonction de leur poids dans
l'hémicycle il y a donc une majorité
contre cette réforme
certains socialistes yvoient un moyen de
ralentir le texte il y a toujours des
gens qui feront des petites manœuvres
qu'on va essayer de mettre des petits
obstacles comme ça bon moi ça ne
m'intéresse pas la procédure
parlementaire les obstructions
parlementaires mais je connais ça par
coeur on s'en sort toujours ce qui
compte c'est le fond et le fond c'est
que je veux des régions fortes dans ce
pays c'est important non mais c'est pas
terrible
après une heure de discussion l'UMP
Jean-Jacques est nommé président de
cette commission spéciale
mais celui qui doit monter au front
c'est lui Michel Dolbar le rapporteur du
texte
mais est-ce qu'on arrivera pousser tout
le monde dans le même sens c'est pas
encore garantie oh ça va être difficile
avec difficile mais notre on est tout de
même l'assemblée qui représente les
collectivités territoriales notre boulot
c'est de faire avancer ce type de texte
voilà
et pour cause la Commission a tout juste
une semaine pour faire des auditions et
élaborer un nouveau texte à partir de
celui du gouvernement des auditions qui
tournent vite au bureau des plantes chez
moi ça va se traduire dans les zones à 7
habitants au kilomètre carré sachant que
la moyenne de ce département des
plaintes concernant la carte bien
évidemment mais aussi le sort des
départements est-ce que vous pensez
qu'éventuellement
la carte des régions pourrait être
modifié en sortant des départements de
certaines régions et le département
c'est quand même le lieu de la
mutualisation le lieu aussi de la
garantie de l'égalité des droits en
filigrane à horizon 2020 le président
Hollande a annoncé la suppression des
conseils généraux une mesure qui touche
directement beaucoup de sénateurs
on sent très bien qu'il est très
difficile à chacun de sortir
de
du rôle qu'il a sur les territoires par
exemple vous sentez qu'au-delà pour
prendre pour être très clair au-delà des
clivages politiques les Présidents de
Conseils généraux
sont sur leur pas tous
la grande majorité mais pas tous sont
sur une position
d'incompréhension par rapport à une
évolution du département
une semaine de travaux qui se solde par
un échec la commission spéciale n'arrive
pas à se mettre d'accord sur sa version
du projet de loi par 16 voies contre 14
le texte est rejeté
le rapporteur lui-même pourtant
socialiste s'abstient
le travail de la commission part à la
poubelle c'est donc le texte du
Gouvernement qui sera présenté en séance
la commission spéciale en toute et pour
tout elle a dû faire 4h ou 5 heures
d'audition à la va vite elle s'est
réunie un jeudi matin et on a redessiné
une carte en trois quarts d'heure est-ce
que vous pensez sérieusement est-ce que
les Français peuvent penser sérieusement
qu'on découpe de grandes régions de
cette manière là en trois quarts d'heure
au gré des rapports de force entre tel
ou tel président de région
aujourd'hui je ne suis pas capable de
dire ce qui va sortir de la séance on
est en train de crisper la totalité des
territoires français et le fait que même
des socialistes ne votent pas le rapport
ce matin provient le consensus est
quasiment impossible à faire si on ne
laisse pas plus de temps au territoire
dans les territoires aussi la bataille
s'organise en Picardie c'est le conseil
régional lui-même dirigé par le
socialiste Claude jewerk qui fait
campagne contre le projet de loi on nous
dit vous allez vous marier avec
Champagne-Ardenne et les Picards disent
nous sommes picards et nos cousins
germains sont les Ch'tis je sens une
opposition très très forte des Picards
aller se marier avec Champagne-Ardenne
une campagne du conseil régional
largement diffusée sur Internet
c'est vrai mais on nous a pas demandé la
permission et c'est non
au Sénat les opposants au texte vont
désormais utiliser toutes les procédures
pour bloquer cette réforme d'abord
l'alliance de circonstances entre le MP
radicaux de gauche et communiste saisit
le Conseil constitutionnel et c'est
retirer le projet de loi de l'ordre du
jour
motif l'étude sur les conséquences de la
réforme fournies par le gouvernement
leur semble insuffisante en fait cette
étude impact il y a pratiquement rien
dedans ça a été fait sur le coin d'une
table et donc nous avons dénoncé cela en
disant oui pour travailler mais avec des
éléments fiables le Conseil
constitutionnel débute les opposants et
la position du gouvernement
24 heures de perdues pour le texte
mais ces opposants ne désarment pas
il y a encore des moyens de procédure
qui sont à notre disposition par exemple
une motion tendance à soumettre le texte
à un référendum ça c'est tout à fait
possible
c'est d'ailleurs ce que vont demander
les groupes communistes et radicaux de
gauche une motion référendaire pour que
la boutisse il faut une adoption par les
deux Chambres les territoires comme
d'habitude
le Sénat adopte la motion mais
l'assemblée elle ne veut pas de se
référer un homme sur la question des
régions cette nouvelle manœuvre des
opposants au texte échouent
est-ce que c'est vrai on fait tout pour
ralentir
donc on le frein d'un petit peu mais
c'est normal ça fait partie du jeu
parlementaire
ce qui m'étonne c'est que certains est
complètement perdu la mémoire
parce qu'on nous faisait qu'est-ce
qu'elle fait ça faisait trois jours
avant de commencer un texte quand la
gauche socialiste était dans
l'opposition trois jours ils arrivaient
à nous faire toutes les procédures les
vaccins les suspensions tout le Corum
enfin nous a tout fait alors qu'on
vienne pas ensuite nous dire que on fait
du retardement
le jeudi 3 juillet avec 48 heures de
retard sur le calendrier le texte arrive
enfin en séance au Sénat pour un dernier
et l'ombre affaire
en première ligne Bernard Cazeneuve venu
défendre sa loi
derrière le cérémonial les deux camps
affûtent leurs armes ils savent que le
combat sera rude mais ignore combien de
temps il va durer
la parole est à Monsieur le Premier
ministre Jean-Pierre rafferin
c'était pas très élégant mais c'était
surtout une faute de nous mêler monsieur
crata chez moi en permanence assez
hauteur du rapport gratin girafarin sur
la réforme territoriale en 2013 salué
par l'ensemble de ses collègues
Jean-Pierre Raffarin donne un premier
coup annoncé en même temps la Grande
Région et la suppression du département
c'est sans prendre à la proximité c'est
sans prendre à la décentralisation parce
que la tribune il va même prendre
directement le ministre à partir je vous
assure que votre réforme si vous nous la
confiez ou la sortirez alors que
vous-même vous êtes aujourd'hui en
situation très difficile pour sortir
quelque chose de positif imperturbable
le ministre de l'Intérieur répond point
par point aux attaques avec ce flegme
qui est sa marque de fabrique monsieur
Raffarin je n'ai jamais dit que vous
préconisez la suppression du département
je dis simplement parce que je suis
précis et rigoureux que vous préconisez
qu'on fasse de grandes régions et que
vous dites dans le rapport ce qui est
vrai ce qui est vrai que ce qui compte
pour les régions de demain c'est leur
taille parce que c'est la taille de la
région qui fera la pertinence de son
efficacité il y a pas de raison de ne
pas prendre des idées qui ont été
développées dans des rapports
parlementaires même s'ils ont été
rédigés par des sénateurs de
l'opposition et c'est ce que nous
faisons
la séance est levée la guerre d'usure
commence désormais il faut tenir les
sénateurs quittent l'hémicycle après
minuit ils ne sont toujours pas rentrés
dans le vif du texte et dans les
couloirs les tractations vont bon train
une carte qui n'aura pas un consensus
pour ceux qui leur ont voté pour le
gouvernement ce sera un fan vous avez vu
la carte
la nuit sera courte pour les sénateurs
mais leur portera tel conseil
le lendemain matin vendredi 4 juillet
deuxième journée de séance et deuxième
round sur ce texte au cœur du débat le
premier article de la loi la carte le
gouvernement maintient la pression si
l'article 1 tombe le texte et vide et de
sens
er à l'art
icle péda va pouvoir aller jusqu'au bout
du texte serait utile pour le
gouvernement parce que je le répète le
gouvernement s'enrichit de tout ce qui
peut se dire au Sénat et ce serait utile
aussi pour le Sénat de montrer qu'il a
envie d'aller jusqu'au bout du débat
même si à la fin le texte est rejeté
qu'au moins on en débattre totalement
les opposants au texte en décident
autrement
après plus de 7 heures de débats sans
surprise la carte et rejeter
la carte n'était pas mûre ça arrange
tout le monde de faire tomber l'article
puisque je crois que les désaccords
traversaient les groupes des grands
rentrés dans le détail des fusions
est-ce que la région Centre allait avec
les Pays de la Loire les Pays de la
Loire avec la Bretagne on voyait que
tout ça n'était pas encore mûr
mais les ministres
et meubles il reste des articles à
examiner et notamment le calendrier des
élections départementales des régionales
prévues au printemps 2015 le
gouvernement souhaite les reporter à
décembre 2015
vous souhaitez vous intervenir monsieur
le ministre une suspension de séance
oui
pour 5 minutes ça vous va très bien la
séance est suspendue elle sera reprise à
moins 25
face à certains amendements déposés par
son propre camp Bernard Cazeneuve
n'hésite pas à faire suspendre la séance
pour recadrer ses troupes
pour la première fois le ministre semble
perdre patience il organise un
conciliabule dans un coin de la salle
des conférences les sénateurs
socialistes rentrent dans leur rang
monsieur les ministres monsieur le
Président de la Commission mes chers
collègues la séance est reprise donc il
y a pas lieu d'avoir peur il y a tout
lieu d'être rassuré puisque nous avons
le temps puisque nous avons la méthode
puisque nous avons les précautions qui
permettent d'éviter que ne se produisent
jamais ce que vous redoutez mais
l'opposition au texte gagne une dernière
bataille et fait supprimer l'article 12
exit le nouveau calendrier
pour l'adoption 184 contre 129 le Sénat
a adopté le projet de loi relatif à la
délimitation des régions aux élections
régionales et départementales et
modifiant le calendrier électoral
après deux jours de débat houleux en
séance le Sénat adopte finalement un
texte sans carte et sans calendrier
toute la soirée non je vous avais dit
que je ne parlerai pas ce soir
un camouflet pour le gouvernement et la
majorité au Sénat
ce sentiment de déception de regret
parce que nous n'avons pas accompli
l'oeuvre que nous aurions dû accomplir
le Sénat chambre des collectivités
aurait dû pousser ce texte pourraient dû
améliorer la carte des régions aurait dû
avancer sur l'ensemble des articles je
regrette que en transfert à l'Assemblée
la qualité de ce texte sans avoir pu la
ranger l'améliorer le faire progresser
même si nous avons obtenu des avancées
certains points mais c'est pas
l'essentiel l'objectif c'est de
clarifier les compétences c'est de faire
des grandes régions c'était de
réaménager
l'administration territoriale nous
n'avons pas réussi à le faire j'ai peur
que le Sénat soit tiré une balle dans le
pied j'espère que les gens ne se
poseront pas la question de à quoi sert
le Sénat si nous n'arrivons pas à avoir
une majorité transversale sur des sujets
comme cela le Sénat est libre
il est évident que cela gêne beaucoup
tous les gouvernements quel que soit la
sensibilité politique de chaque
gouvernement et pourquoi
il en est voulu au Sénat parce que le
Sénat a l'habitude de travailler sur le
fond et d'exprimer sa liberté dans
l'intérêt de la République
le Sénat a donc adopté la réforme
territoriale mais un texte vidé de la
substance voulue par le gouvernement
sans nouvelle carte ni calendrier des
élections locales
parmi les apports de la chambre haute
tout de même une meilleure
représentation des départements ruraux
dans les conseils régionaux et un droit
d'option pour les départements
pendant ce temps l'Assemblée nationale a
avancé et proposé sont redécoupage au
Sénat désormais d'imposer sa marque en
deuxième lecture à l'automne une fois
les élections sénatoriales passées avec
un nouveau président du Sénat et
peut-être une nouvelle majorité
à la Pentecôte la Feria de Nîmes attire
près